[Musique]
vous vous êtes fait refaire les fesses
[Rires]
des surnoms emerging de l'aubrac et de
jeu contre elle a même filmé son
opération regarder abandonné l'opération
si vous avez du mal à vous asseoir
c'est ça que j'aime pied par terre un
pied à maintien et vous avez tout
compris vous allez faire rajouter quoi
en fait j'ai enlevé mon gras ouais vous
l'avez dans les failles d'accord
d'accord c'est mon projet merci et non
mais ça fait mal non ah oui my
d'ailleurs christophe maé a fait une
chanson pour ces faits
écoute en boucle c'est ça je franchement
vous êtes très joli mais j étais déjà
magnifique non mais vraiment été du
jardin public
vous pouvez prendre l'avion tout ça y'a
pas que tu dis alors je vais map l'avant
demain dans le taxi je suis venu à plat
ventre
oui assez un sketch à chaque mois
pendant un mois j'ai pas droit de
masseube à moi de lui vendre le likoud
et ça sonne pas l'aéroport
comment ça donne ça allait passer mais
ça va ce naturel puisque c'est mon grâce
à une sanction parce qu'on sera d'accord
d'accord va très bien en tout cas merci
d'être là avec kesha comporte
merci merci merci